this is not a sonic boom but a quick
search of google images will tell you
otherwise
image after image after image all
showing something that is not a sonic
boom
so if this is not a sonic boom what is
it
to answer that question we first need to
address what a sonic boom is shock waves
occur as a result of the maximum speed
of sound which is the speed pressure
waves can travel which we perceive as
sound
the speed of sound in air is around 340
meters per second but that does change
with atmospheric conditions primarily
temperature
so let's imagine a stationary object it
releases a sound wave periodically which
propagates out at 340 meters per second
these sound waves are just areas of high
pressure air traveling outwards
now when the object starts to accelerate
we can see that the distance between the
sound waves behind the object increases
and the distance between the sound waves
in front of the object decreases
the pressure waves can't travel any
faster than 340 meters per second and
the object is catching up with them and
when it does catch up with them
something weird happens the sound waves
begin to stack up on each other causing
a sudden spike in pressure this pressure
wave is incredibly thin it's just a thin
band of molecules colliding because they
can't get out of each other's way fast
enough
only 100 to 200 nanometers wide the
human eye can't see this under normal
conditions but that high pressure air
does distort light through refraction
and with the right tools we can use that
to visualize shock waves using schlarin
imaging and shadow graphs here you can
see the sound wave propagating out of
the gun when it's fired then the bullet
traveling faster than the speed of sound
bursts from the gun and catches up with
the sound wave while forming its own
conical shock wave
this is the only way we can see a shock
wave directly through light distortion
so if this is not a shock wave what is
it
what we are seeing here is water
condensing in the air because of a
temperature drop
water vapor in the air is typically
invisible we can only see water vapor
when the air is too saturated with water
to absorb any more we can achieve this
by increasing the water content in the
air like when we boil water and we can
see the water vapor rising from it or by
decreasing the temperature of the air
warmer air is capable of holding more
moisture so if we were at 100
absolute humidity the maximum amount of
water the air can hold at 30 degrees
there would be about 30 grams of water
vapor per meter cubed of air but if we
drop the air temperature to zero degrees
celsius the maximum amount of water
vapor that air could hold would be only
5 grams per meter cubed
when the air temperature drops like this
water is forced to come out of the air
and form visible water vapor like clouds
or these vapor cones
that's what we're seeing here a sudden
drop in temperature that forces water
out of the air but shock waves cause a
spike in pressure increases in pressure
cause an increase in temperature not a
decrease
and that's really why we aren't seeing a
shockwave we are seeing the exact
opposite of a shockwave we are seeing an
expansion fan
expansion fans occur when supersonic
flow travels over an area where the flow
is given space to expand in particular
convex corners like over the convex
curve of the canopy or after the
thickest part of the wing and that's
exactly where we see vapor cones form on
all of these videos my favorite example
of this is this video of the discovery
space shuttle launching on july 13 1995
carrying a communication satellite to
orbit we can see vapor cones as the air
travels over the convex corners of the
solid rocket booster and the shuttle's
flight deck in videos like this one of
the fa18 the vapor cone flickers in and
out of intensity as it travels through
areas of higher and lower humidity
that's why we don't always see a vapor
cone we can only see it in the right
conditions where that expansion of air
causes a high enough decrease in
temperature to force water out of
solution
so we aren't seeing a shock wave here we
are seeing the exact opposite an
expansion fan of course we can see
condensation like this occur well below
supersonic speeds like when high angle
of attack maneuvers cause rapid
expansions of air behind the wing but
there is a kind of shock wave we can see
a shock wave that occurs when something
travels faster than the speed of light
many of you will be looking at the
screen with a raised eyebrow right now
but what you are looking at right now
are shock waves of light caused by
electrons traveling faster than light in
water in the extended cut of this video
available exclusively on nebula i have
included an explanation of how exactly
this happens and the phenomenons uses in
engineering if you are a fan of this
channel nebula is the best place to
watch everything we make when possible
we upload our videos early to nebula all
advertisements are cut from the nebula
versions of my videos and our next video
the insane engineering of the 787 will
be uploaded to nebula as a nearly
hour-long director's cut next month
which we are going to have to cut into
smaller 15 to 20 minute versions for
youtube as 60 minutes is just too long
for the youtube algorithm gods to
approve of you can also get exclusive
content from us on nebula like our
logistics of d-day series or you could
learn about my life before youtube in
lowspecgamer's excellent nebula
exclusive podcast genesis where you can
learn the story of how i quit my job in
engineering to start this channel how
advanced was the youtube channel at that
point that you were confident enough to
quit your job i don't think i'd uploaded
anything at that stage i can't remember
wow you wait you quit before creating a
youtube channel
the best way to get access to nebula is
by signing up through curiositystream
which is available for the extremely low
discounted rate of 14.79 a year a little
over one dollar a month
this is by far the best way to support
this channel and you get something in
return with access to both nebula and
all of the award-winning documentaries
on curiosity stream like this
fascinating biography of neil
armstrong's life narrated by harrison
ford you can sign up to this amazing
deal by clicking on this button on
screen right now
or if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you could watch our
last video on how blended wings could
change air travel forever or you could
watch real science's latest video on how
hybrid bears are taking over the north